the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi technically speaking I suppose if
time permitted we should spend or shall
we say give equal time to integral
calculus at the same time that we gave
to differential calculus starting from
scratch building ideas slowly and the
like but there are two logistic reasons
for not doing this one of which is that
the basic definitions would be the same
regardless of which branch we started
with the second one is of course the
time becomes preciously tight and we
have to make the best of what we can
here so what we're going to do now is
try to show in terms of hindsight being
better than foresight a motivation as to
how one would have invented differential
calculus
had it been motivated by the existing
integral calculus in other words what we
want to do today is to show the
beautiful interplay between differential
and integral calculus since we have said
in our last lecture that we would like
to begin with a study of integral
calculus assuming that differential
calculus had never been invented I think
that we obligated to try to show how
then differential calculus could have
been invented in the environment of the
studying of areas for this reason I have
called today's lecture the marriage of
differential and integral calculus and
essentially the idea goes something like
this last time we were talking about
finding areas under a curve and to find
the area under the curve we saw that we
could do this as the limit of a certain
sum in other words an infinite sum
having a particular limit now to
motivate the concept of rate of change
one could ask the following question a
curve like y equals f of X and a
starting point x equals a as I move out
along the x axis from a I can study the
area under the curve say from Y of the
curve y equals f of X from x equals a to
some value x1 and the questions I could
then ask is I wonder how fast this area
is changing at the instant that x equals
x1 in other words how fast is the area
changing under the curve
as X moves out along the positive x-axis
this way you see now the idea is this
I can then mimic the same definition
that we gave for instantaneous rate of
change in differential calculus namely I
can say why can't we define the
instantaneous rate of change to be the
average rate of change with respect to X
and then we'll take the limit as Delta X
approaches 0 etc and if I do that
watch what happens over here you see
what I do in terms of this picture is I
say okay here's the area under the curve
when X is equal to x1 now I'll let x1
change by some amount Delta X meaning
this would be the point x1 plus Delta X
and this brings about a change in my
area which I'll call Delta a see the
change in area as X goes from x1 to X 1
plus Delta X now what I would like to
find is Delta a divided by Delta X taken
in the limit as Delta X approaches 0
remember last time we showed our three
basic axioms for area we obliged to
still use them let's do that here for
example the way I've drawn this curve by
rising this way
notice that the lowest point in this
interval occurs when x equals x1 the
highest point occurs when x equals x1
plus Delta X consequently the rectangle
whose base is the closed interval from X
1 to X 1 plus Delta X the rectangle
whose height corresponds to x equals x 1
is too small
in area to be Delta a in other words
that rectangle is inscribed in Delta a
and in the same way the rectangle with
base X 1 to X 1 plus delta X whose
height is given by the x-coordinate x1
plus Delta X that rectangle has an area
which is too large to be the exact area
in other words notice that the area of
the rectangle which is too small to be
the exact area is f of x1 times Delta X
the area of the rectangle which is too
big to be the correct Delta a is f of x1
plus Delta x times Delta X and the area
Delta a is caught between these two in
other words we now have the
quality that f of X 1 times Delta X is
less than Delta a which in turn is less
than f of X 1 plus Delta x times Delta X
now we'll assume that Delta X is
positive the way we've drawn this
diagram adjustments have to be made if
Delta X is negative in other words if we
let Delta X approach 0 through negative
values this is taken care of in the
textbook as well as mentioned in our
notes but for the sake of just getting
the main idea here we'll assume that
Delta X is positive we divide through by
Delta X that gives us f of X 1 is less
than Delta a over Delta X which in turn
is less than f of x1 plus Delta X in
other words had Delta X been negative we
would have had to reverse the inequality
signs etc but we're not going to worry
about that right now remember what is
Delta X it's a nonzero number which is
going to be made to become arbitrarily
close to zero well here's the idea we
now have Delta a over Delta X squeezed
between these two values and we say okay
let's let Delta X approach zero now
here's the key point as Delta X
approaches zero
certainly x1 plus Delta X approaches x1
and here's where we use the fact that F
is continuous in other words notice that
the mid fact that x1 plus Delta X
approaches x1 is not enough to say
therefore that F of x1 plus Delta X
approaches F of x1 as we saw before
that's only true if F is continuous in
other words by continuity if x1 plus
Delta X approaches x1 then F of x1 plus
Delta X approaches F of x1 so assuming
then that F is continuous what do we get
when we put the squeeze on x1 is was
picked to be a fixed point consequently
as Delta X approaches 0 f of x1 stays F
of x1 f of x1 plus Delta X approaches F
of x1 in other words Delta a divided by
Delta X is caught between two numbers
two sequences two sets of bounds
whichever way you want to say this both
of which converge to the common limit f
of x1 in other words sin
Delta a over Delta X is squeezed between
these two the limit of Delta a over
Delta X as Delta X approaches zero must
equal this common limit in other words
da/dx the limit of Delta a over Delta X
as Delta X approaches zero evaluated at
x equals x1 is f of x1 or another way of
saying this da DX is f of X now that
result is partly intuitive and partly
remarkable what it says is roughly
speaking is that the area under the
curve is changing at a rate equal
instantaneously to the height
corresponding to the x coordinate at
that point in other words that defined
how fast the area is changing as X moves
all you have to do is measure the height
of the curve corresponding to that
particular value of x okay now what does
this have to do then with relating
integral and differential calculus
notice already we begin to get some sort
of a hint what we've shown is now that
the area is going to be related to
somehow to the inverse derivative of f
of X in fact this is precisely what is
meant by a rather important result in
fact it's important enough so it's
called the first fundamental theorem of
integral calculus and it simply says
this suppose we know explicitly a
function capital G such that the
derivative of capital g is f where the f
now refers to the f that we're talking
about in our problem now look at what we
already know is that a the area function
has its derivative equal to f
consequently since the area function and
G have the same derivative they must
differ by at most a constant in other
words the area as a function of X is
this function G of X plus C and what is
this G of X it's not any old function
it's what an inverse derivative of f of
X since the area evaluated x equals a is
0 C namely the area under the
curved as X goes from A to A that's a
sinister line a line has no thickness
has no area this is zero we have by
plugging back into here that a of little
a is zero that in turn is G of a plus C
and solving this for C we find that C is
equal to minus G of a in other words the
area under the curve y equals f of X as
a function of X is simply what its G of
X minus G of a where G is any function
whose derivative is f if we now let X
equal B we're back to the situation of
finding the usual region that we're
talking about here namely what is a sub
R it's the region bounded above let's
come back here and take a look at this
it's the region bounded above by the
curve y equals f of X bounded on the
left by x equals a on the right by x
equals B and below by the x-axis
according to this notation the area of
the region R is just the area as a
function of X when X 1 is equal to B in
other words the area of our region R is
just a of B which is G of B minus G of a
where G is any function whose derivative
is f now remember and here's the key
point remember that the area of the
region R did not result did not
necessitate us having to know a function
whose derivative was F in other words
remember in our last lecture how did we
find areas of regions like R what we did
was is we form these u sub ends these L
sub ends we inscribed and circumscribed
networks of rectangles put the squeeze
on by evaluating this particular limit
and whenever that limit was that was the
area of the region R in other words if I
had never heard of the inverse
derivative I could still find the area
of the region R this way however if I
just happen to know a function G whose
derivative is f I have a much easier way
of doing this fact let me summarize that
you see that is we can compute the limit
as n approaches infinity summation K
goes from 1 to N
F of C sub K Delta X by use of inverse
derivatives C again the highlight being
what you can still work with this the
same way as we did in our last lecture
there is no need there is absolutely no
need to have had to ever heard of a
derivative to solve this type of problem
even though it may be messy now what's
the best proof I have of this well I
guess one of the best proofs is to
specifically refer to one of the
exercises in the previous unit
there was a tough exercise I did as a
learning exercise because I felt it was
something that was messy and that you
have to be guided through in order not
to become hopelessly lost by way of
review the problem was this we took as
our region our the region bounded above
by y equals sine X below by the x-axis
on the right by the line x equals PI
over 2 and the problem was to find the
area of the region R and we solve this
problem in the last unit without
recourse to derivatives because as of
the time that we were in the last unit
we had no results relating derivatives
to limits of sums how do we do this we
partition this into n parts and we
formed the sum limit as n approaches
infinity Sigma K goes from 1 to n we
broke this thing up into n equal parts
so the size of each piece was what PI
over 2 divided by n that's PI over 2 n
we computed the sine of each of these
endpoints etc and whatever that limit
was that was the area of the region R
and as you recall that homework problem
we found that the answer to that problem
was that the area of the region R was 1
ok now again as messy as that was it
proved that we could at least solve the
problem with no knowledge of derivatives
how does the first fundamental theorem
apply here the way the first fundamental
theorem applies is the following the
first fundamental theorem says this look
at to evaluate this particular sum all
we have to do is find a function whose
derivative is sine X she knows in this
problem the general a and B of the above
is now played by Abe
zero and B equals PI over two all we
have to do is what find the function G
whose derivative is sine X and the
answer should then be G of PI over 2
minus G of 0 well you see this happens
to be one that with our knowledge of
differential calculus we can do rather
easily in other words do we at the tip
of our tongues have a function whose
derivative is sine X and the answer is
yes since the derivative of cosine X is
minus sine X the derivative of minus
cosine X is sine X in other words we can
choose for our G of X here minus cosine
X in other words that the area of the
region R should be what G of PI over 2
minus G of 0 where G of X is minus
cosine X well you see cosine PI over 2
is 0 cosine of 0 is 1 so 0 minus -1 is
equal to 1 and notice that first of all
we get the same answer and secondly
notice this two line job over here we
not only get the correct answer but we
get the answer very much more rapidly
than we did by the so called limit
process now you know I'll come back to
this in a minute because you may be a
little bit angry at me now namely you
may be asking after having to do this
problem the hard way why did I have to
do the usual teachers trick here and
show you the hard way of doing this and
then waiting til the next unit before I
show you the easy way well there happens
to be a catch here that I'll come back
to in just a moment
but before I do that I'd like to make an
aside an aside that's rather important
namely you may recall as I started to
work over here that this reminded you of
a notation that we were using back when
we introduced the concept of the inverse
of differentiation namely amazingly we
earlier used the notation integral from
A to B f of X DX to denote G of B minus
G of a where G prime equals F what we
have shown by the first fundamental
theorem then using this notation is that
the area of the region R is
integral from A to B f of X DX in other
words this means what it means G of B
minus G of a where G prime equals F ok
let's pause here for a moment see as we
developed our course this is how this
would evolve the interesting thing is
that historically this notation was not
used to define G of B minus G of a where
G prime equal F
historically what happened was that this
notation called the definite integral
the integral from A to B f of X DX was I
don't know if it's proper to say
invented but let me just say it in
quotation marks to play it safe it was
invented to denote the limit of this sum
in fact notice how much more meaningful
the symbol looks in this connotation in
other words this is the limit of a sum
you can think of some as beginning with
s and the integral sign is an elongated
s in other words when one first wrote
this symbol the definite integral it was
meant to denote this limit the important
point is that by the first fundamental
theorem the definite integral whether
it's a limit or not to insult ibly G of
B minus G of a where G prime equals F in
other words it really makes no
difference in terms of what answer you
get whether you think of this definite
integral as meaning this or whether you
think of the definite integral as
meaningless see numerically they'll be
the same but conceptually they're quite
different and that's precisely the point
that leads to the most I think probably
the most difficult part of the course at
least up until now it's something that
more people cause and have
misinterpretation over and so I'd like
to present this in a very very gradual
way see the result will ultimately be
known as the second fundamental theorem
of integral calculus I've taken the
liberty of writing that over here but
it's going to be quite a while before I
actually say what the theorem is
explicitly what I'd like to do is to
pick up where I left off when I made my
aside about the No
pation of the definite integral and well
let the mention now is for the person
who says look at why did you make us
find areas the hard way why didn't you
just say what let us compute G of B
minus G of a where G prime equals F and
the heck with all this summation process
now I think the best way to answer that
question and it is probably the ultimate
in teaching technique when somebody
thinks that he has an easier way than
the way that he was taught give him a
problem that can't be done by that
easier way in fact as a sarcastic aside
if you can't invent that kind of a
problem maybe the so called easier way
is the better way of doing the thing but
let me just show you what I'm driving at
over here suppose I say to you let's
find the area of the region R where R is
now the following its bounded above by
the curve y equals 1 over X it's bounded
below by the x-axis it's bounded on the
left by the line x equals 1 and on the
right by the line x equals 2 I would
like to find the area of this region R
now look at from a purely conceptual
point of view what difference is there
between this problem and the problem
where the upper curve was y equals x
squared conceptually what's going on is
the same thing we have a bounded region
and we want to compute the area to this
end
notice that if I use the precise
definition of the definite integral the
area of the region R is what the
definite integral from 1 to 2 DX over X
ok what does that mean it means a
particular limit what limit
well you partition this interval from 1
to 2 into n equal parts pick a point C
sub K and each partition then f of C sub
K in this problem is just 1 over C sub K
in other words what we want to do is to
compute this limit Sigma K goes from 1
to N 1 over C sub K times Delta X now
the thing to notice is this thing may be
a mess but it's computable we could use
you know specially design graph paper or
measuring devices to count the units of
area under here we can find all sorts of
ways of getting estimates
even the long hard way of the use of
ends and the ELSA bends to pinpoint the
area of the region R - as close a degree
of accuracy as we want etc the point is
that if we have never heard of a
derivative the area of the region R is
given precisely by this sum and
admittedly this sum is a mess
ok so let's try and do it the so called
easier way the skeptic looks at this
thing and says who needs this the area
of the region R we just saw by the first
fundamental theorem is G of 2 G of 2
minus G of 1 where G is any function of
X whose derivative with respect to X is
1 over X and the answer to that is yes
so far so good but do we know a function
G whose derivative with respect to X is
1 over X remember this is calculus
revisited for those of you who remember
calculus from the first time around and
I'll talk about this later
it's going to turn out that the required
G is a logarithmic function for those of
you who don't remember that there's no
harm and not remembering that all I'm
trying to bring out is that whether you
remember it or you don't as far as we're
concerned so far in this course as far
as what we've developed in this course
we do not know a function G whose
derivative with respect to X is 1 over X
that's what we mean by saying we can't
exhibit G explicitly what do I mean by
that
somebody says I am thinking of a
function whose derivative is 1 over X I
say well that's simple its G of X he
says well what's G of X I said that's
the function whose derivative with
respect to X is 1 over X well you see
that implicitly tells me what G is like
but in terms of concrete measurements I
don't know anything about G I can't
express it in terms of well-known
familiar functions you see I'm hung up
now namely this is precise the answer to
this problem will be G of 2 minus G of 1
where G prime is 1 over X but I don't
know explicitly thanks
I don't know explicitly such a G and I
put the exclamation point out here to
emphasize that particular fact ok that's
the hang-up this
statement that says that the area is G
of B minus G of a where G prime equals F
hinges on the fact that you can
explicitly exhibit such a G certainly if
you can't exhibit that G you can still
compute this area as a limit it would be
tragic to say oh the area doesn't exist
the area doesn't exist because I don't
know what G whose derivative is 1 over X
certainly this region R has an area in
fact because we can pinpoint the area of
the region R we can actually construct
the G such that G prime of X equals 1
over X and by the way there's plenty of
drill on this this is a hard concept and
as a result you will notice that the
exercises in this section hammer home on
this point because it's a point that I'm
positive that if you having trouble at
all with integral calculus this is
certainly the most sophisticated part of
what we're doing right now you see look
at suppose I want to construct the
function G whose derivative is 1 over X
the idea looks something like this I'm
on the integral from 1 to 2 here what I
do is I plot the curve y equals 1 over X
and I compute the area of the region
formed by the curve y equals 1 over X x
equals 1 the x-axis and the line y
equals x equals x1 this is my region R
and what I say is look at what do I know
about this area remember what I started
this lecture with was the knowledge that
a prime of X is f of X f of X in this
case is 1 over X in other words what
property does this area function have it
has the property that it's derivative
with respect to X is going to be 1 over
X in other words if I now say look at
voice I can compute this area if not
exactly at least to as many decimal
place accuracy as I wish so that the
area function is something I can
construct let me define G of X 1 simply
to be the area under this curve when X
is equal to X 1
in other words written now is the limit
see how this definite integral comes in
here written as integral from 1 to X sub
1 DX over X
which I now can compute as closely as I
want as a limit the beauty is what that
G prime of x1 is by definition a prime
of x1 and we have already seen that the
derivative of a is F where F is the top
curve in this case the derivative a is 1
over X in other words the area under the
curve explicitly can be computed as a
function of X and that function has the
property that it's derivative with
respect to X in this case is 1 over X
you see and by the way let me make just
a quick aside over here I happen to
throw in the wood logarithms before it's
going to turn out as we'll talk about in
our next block of material that G of X
turns out to be the natural log of X
which means that the area of the region
R is precisely natural log 2 now the
idea is and this is exactly what's going
to happen in our last block in our
course that this is exactly how the log
tables are constructed in fact I mean
how do you think they find the log of
two to eight decimal places if they
strand somebody on a desert island and
tell them to compute these things
measure it with laser beams what know
the way we do it is is we know it's an
area and knowing how to find the area as
a limit to as many decimal place
accuracy as we wish give or take a few
tricks of the trade this is how we find
logs and later on trigonometric tables
and the like but I just mentioned this
as an aside to show you how important
knowing area under a curve is at any
rate to summarize what we're saying over
here we have the following in general if
F is any continuous function on the
closed interval from A to B we define a
function G as follows G of x1 is the
definite integral from a to X 1 f of X
DX where x1 is any point in the closed
interval from A to B what does this
thing mean geometrically it's the area
under the curve y equals f of X on top x
equals the x-axis on the bottom the line
x equals a on the left the line x equals
x1 on the right and that area is what
it's the limit as n approaches infinity
Sigma K goes from 1 to N F of C sub K
Dell
etc etc etc meaning we can go through
this the same way as we did in our
previous lecture this function G of x1
which we can now compute explicitly as
an area because we have the curve F
drawn we can approximate it to as close
to the Greve accuracies we want whatever
that function G is what properly doesn't
have it has the property that G prime is
equal to F and that's exactly what the
second fundamental theorem really means
the second fundamental theorem says look
at if you can compute the area you can
now reverse this procedure that we were
talking about in the first fundamental
theorem see in the first fundamental
theorem what did we do in the first
fundamental theorem we found a quick way
of computing the area as a limit by
knowing the appropriate inverse
derivative the second fundamental
theorem in a sense is the inverse of the
first fundamental theorem namely it
switch it switches the roles namely with
the second fundamental theorem what we
say is this if we know how to find the
area under the curve y equals f of X
that gives us a way of computing a
function G whose derivative IS F in fact
to summarize this that in this is very
important let me just summarize this
then first of all the first fundamental
theorem allows us to compute this
particular limit provided we can find a
G such that G prime equals F in fact in
this case the limit as n approaches
infinity summation K goes from 1 to n F
of C sub K Delta X is given very very
ingeniously beautifully and concisely by
G of B minus G of a secondly the second
fundamental theorem allows us given F to
construct G such that G prime equals F
namely the required G is just the
definite integral from a to X 1 f of X
DX which in turn is a limit of a network
of rectangles namely the limit as n
approaches infinity summation K goes
from 1 to n F of C sub K
delta x this then is perhaps the most
beautiful lecture in calculus not
necessarily the way i've given it but in
terms of what relating to apparently
diverse branches of calculus integral
and differential calculus this is a
difficult subject I have taken great
pains to try to write this clearly in
the supplementary notes I have tried to
pick typical exercises that bring home
these highlights and in addition our
next two lectures will emphasize the
relationship between derivatives and
integrals as we study volume and arc
length at any rate until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate